la loi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui va prendre l'escalier je prends
l'ascenseur escaliers quoi et voulez
vous la l'ascenseur ses rivaux oui c'est
du cinquième étage où ça le preneur il
va pas il y aura une tarte le 1er rima
en bas aura le droit de mettre la tarte
dans la tête de l'autre d'accord vous
êtes prêts voilà c'est parti au liban
[Applaudissements]
quand on tue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez allez
dans le temps
[Applaudissements]
cantine associés armes et munitions non
j'ai ri c'est le jeu qui vous jouez les
jeunes salariés qui avait ajouté je vois
le joker
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya vincent moscato et jean françois
quéré qui étaient avec nous demain
aujourd'hui sur le film on voulait tout
casser
ils sont dans le tarn ascenseur leuthard
d'ascenseur donc je sais pas qui va
prendre l'ascenseur qui va prendre les
escaliers
déjà ça de l'art mais regardez les bras
il prend l'ascenseur qui prend les
escaliers
ben c'est lui qui prend l'ascenseur nom
et vous prenez les escaliers with the
stars il va avoir un accident dans cette
émission je vous dit tout
c'est sûr et certain temps mais c'est
sûr et certain ça va mal se terminer
on va s'assurer l'habitude comme ça
alors on y va
c'est mardi jean-françois il va sans
dire
[Applaudissements]
attention c'est al attar qu'il faut
qu'il la tente derrière l'ascenseur à 10
puis c'est qu'elle est axée ou dégâts il
ne connaissait pas parce qu'ils
arriver là mais attention attention
[Applaudissements]
j'avale et ses rites lavallois abad et
attendez attendez arrivera tenter je
vous paye à tous ou bien sûr le pressing
joly qui a été touché
[Musique]